hello and welcome back if you are trying
to get a learning algorithm to do a task
that humans can do and if your learning
algorithm is not yet at the performance
of a human then manually examining
mistakes your algorithm is making can
give you insights into what to do next
this process is called error analysis
let's start with an example let's say
you're working on your cat classifier
and you've achieved 90% accuracy or
equivalently 10% error on your deaf set
and let's say this is much worse than
you're hoping to do maybe when your
teammates looks at some of the examples
that the algorithm is misclassifying and
notices that is miscarry writing some
dogs as cats and you know if you look at
these two dogs maybe they look a little
bit like a cat at least at first glance
so maybe your teammate comes to you with
a proposal for how to make the algorithm
do better specifically on dogs it you
can imagine building a focus as it may
be to collect more dark creatures or
maybe into a design features specific
the dogs or something in order to make
your cat classified do better on dogs so
it stops miss recognizing these dogs as
cats so the question is should you go
ahead and start a project focus on the
dog problem there could be several
months of work you could do in order to
make your algorithm make fewer mistakes
on dog pictures so is that worth your
effort well rather than spending a few
months doing this only to risk finding
out at the end that it wasn't that
helpful here's an error analysis
procedure they can let you very quickly
tell whether or not this could be worth
your effort here's what I recommend you
do first get about say 100 mislabeled
death set examples then examine them
manually just count up count them up one
at a time to see how many of these
mislabeled examples in your dev set on
Ashley pictures of dogs now suppose that
it turns out that five percent of your
hundred mislabeled deficit examples are
pictures of dogs
so that is five out of a hundred of
these mislabeled deficit examples are
dogs what this means is that of the
hundred examples of a typical set of
hundred examples are getting wrong even
if you completely solve the dog problem
you only get five out of a hundred more
correct or in other words if only five
percent of your errors are dark pictures
then the best you could easily hope to
do if you spend a lot of time on the
dark problem until your error might go
down from ten percent error down to nine
point five percent error rate so dozens
a five percent relative decrease in
error from ten percent down to nine
point five percent and so you might
reasonably decide that this is not the
best use of your time or maybe it is but
at least this gives you a ceiling or an
upper bound on how much you could
improve performance by working on the
dark problem and the machine learning
sometimes we call it the ceiling on
performance which just means you know
what's in the best case how well could
working on the dog problem help you but
now suppose something else happens
suppose there were you look at your
hundred mislabeled answer examples you
find that fifty of them are actually dog
images so 50% of them are dog pictures
you know you could be much more
optimistic about spending time on the
dog problem in this case if you actually
solve the dog problem your error would
go down from this ten percent down to
potentially five percent error and you
might decide that having your error
could be worth a lot of effort focus on
reducing the problem of mislabeled dogs
I know that in machine learning
sometimes we speak the sarin jingly of
hand engineered things or using too much
value in sight but if you're building
apply systems then this simple counting
procedure error analysis can save you a
lot of time in terms of deciding what's
the most important or what's the most
promising direction to focus on
in fact if you're looking at a hundred
with label deaths of examples maybe this
is a you know five to ten minute effort
to manually go through a hundred
examples and not only count up how many
of them adults and depending on the
outcome whether it's more like five
percent or fifty percent or something
else this in just five to ten minutes
gives you an estimate of how worthwhile
this direction is and could help you
make a much better decision whether or
not to spend the next few months focus
on trying to find solutions to solve the
problem of mislabeled dogs in this slide
will describe using error analysis to
evaluate whether or not a single idea
dogs in this case is worth working on
sometimes you can also evaluate multiple
ideas in parallel during error analysis
for example let's say you have several
ideas for improving your cat detector
maybe you can improve performance on
dogs or maybe notice that sometimes what
they call great tasks such as lions
Panthers cheetahs and so on that they
are being recognized as you know small
cats for house cats so you could maybe
find a way to work on that or maybe you
find that some of your images are blurry
and it would be nice if you could design
something that just works better on
blurry images and maybe have some ideas
on how to do that so if carrying out
error analysis to evaluate these three
ideas what I would do is create a table
like this and I usually do this in a
spreadsheet but using an ordinary text
file will also be okay and on the left
side this goes through these set of
images you plan to look at manually so
this maybe goes from 1 to 100 if you
look at 100 pictures and the columns of
this table of the spreadsheet will
correspond to the IDS devaluating so the
dog problem the problem of three cats
and blurry images and I usually also
leave space in the spreadsheet to write
comments so remember during error
analysis you're just looking at deaths
of examples that your algorithm has miss
recognized
so if you find that the first miss
recognized image is a picture of a dog
not for the checkmark there and to help
myself remember of these images
sometimes I'll make a note in the
comment so maybe there was a football
picture um if the second picture was
blurry then you can know they're on but
the third one was a lion on a rainy day
in the zoo that was miss recognized then
that's a great cat in the Bernie data
make a note in the comment section you
know rainy day at zoo and surveying that
made it very and so on then finally
having gone through some set of images
that would count up what percentage of
these algorithms or what percentage of
each of these error categories were
attributed to the dog or grain cattle
during categories so maybe eight percent
of these images you're examining turn
out to be dogs and maybe forty three
percent great cats and sixty-one percent
were blurry so this just means bring
down each column and Counting up what
percentage of images have a checkmark in
that column as you're part way through
this process sometimes you notice other
categories of this state so for example
you might find that Instagram style
filter those you know fancy image
filters um are also messing up your
crossfire in that case is actually okay
probably through the process to add
another column like that for the
multicolored filter the Instagram
filters and snapchat filters and then go
through and count up those as well and
figure out you know what percentage
comes from that new error Academy the
conclusion of this process gives you an
estimate of how worthwhile it might be
to work on each of these different
categories of errors for example clearly
in this example rather the mistakes were
made on brewery images and quite a lot
were made on great cat images and so the
outcome of this analysis is not that you
must work on very images this doesn't
give you a rigid mathematical formula
that tells you what to do but it gives
you a sense of the best options to
pursue
it also tells you for example that no
matter how much better you do on dog
images are on Instagram images your
animals improve performance by maybe
eight percent or twelve percent in these
examples whereas you can do better on
great cat images or very images the
potential improvement that is the
ceiling in terms of how much you can
improve performance is much higher so
depending on how many ideas you have for
improving performance on great cats on
blurry images maybe you could pick one
of the two or if you have enough
personality maybe even have two
different teams have one work on
improving eras on great cats and the
different team work on improving eras
observing images but this quick
procedure which you can often do in at
most small numbers of hours can really
help you make much better proud to
Malaysian decisions and understand how
promising different approaches are to
work on so to summarise to carry error
analysis you should finally sent in
mislabeled examples I'll leave you dead
set of your development set and look at
the mislabeled examples both false
positives and false negatives and just
count up the number of errors that fall
into various different categories during
this process you might be inspired to
generate new categories of errors like
we saw you looking through the example
you see gee did a lot of Instagram
photos the snapchat filters they're also
messing up my class style you could
create new categories doing their
process but by counting out the fraction
of examples in this label in different
ways often this will help you prioritize
or give you inspiration for new
directions to go in now after doing
error analysis sometimes you notice that
some of the examples you get sit on this
label so what do you do about that let's
discuss that in the next video